so as you he my name is and that person
who always likes to think i to
think so one day when i was was and i
was thinking about something and i think
what has ched in the 2000
[موسيقى]
was us so what hased
our ch
so
[موسيقى]
لاقت
از
[موسيقى]
حواليك
بتخليك
[موسيقى]
يركل حاجه
حو
بشوف
sch
عشان
وحشه
لنا مش
[موسيقى]
ع
عن
ش
[موسيقى]
زم كان
الا
حاجه
[موسيقى]
زمان بنشوف عمر
الشريفان كتير
ل او قميص على البنطلون يكون شكله محترم
ويخلي شكل نيف بس دلوقتي لا دلوقتي بلاقي
الولاد
قميص
اشوف الاولب بقت
دقتها
بلون عليه بعد كده اهم حاجه لازم
تحصلها لازم الطون عشان لا
[موسيقى]
النا
الحجه عليها
منظر عشان انا ممكن ابقى مش لابس
حاجه
مشه
[موسيقى]
مقط
وهف
[موسيقى]
حوك موجود في كل
البلا
[موسيقى]
per they always slender which one thing
that is with bey beauty you have to be
white you have to have white eyes and
you have to be slender but this is not
true a person with brown eyes and n eyes
can still have those aming eyes the
universe while a person with white eyes
that are green might just be
very
these
days in to pra body
but how
my and
stage
this m
and كدي فور اابل كان في برنامج في رمضان
برنامج مقالب طلع اثنين دفان
و الهوست بتاع البرنامج ده سب عليهم طول
البرنامج والمشكله ان هم وافقوا ان
البرنامج ده يتزاع وواحده منهم اك بتطلع
كل اسبوع بتعمل بلاي وبتقبل ان هم كل
اسبوع يتريقوا عليها او على تخنها بعنى
اصح وده خلى ان المفروض لما حد يبقى ماشي
ويترا على دخه ده عادي
[موسيقى]
some
some
عشان
[موسيقى]
من
[تصفيق]
حاجه
اوع
[موسيقى]
بزياده الناس
كلها
[موسيقى]
مش
دلوقتي احنا بنشوف على
انستجرام ازاي تعملي شع بطريقه معينه ازي
تحير لون
[موسيقى]
عين
عادي ان انت يبقى فيك عين او يبقى شكلك
على الاقل مش دايما مظبوط مش يما احنا
[تصفيق]
هدق